e
qui a des exemples que les
choses que les villes peuvent
faire doit faire pour s'adapter.
- Le mot "résilience", qu'on
entend beaucoup dans le jargon
de l'action climatique,
veut d'abord dire : résistance
au choc d'un matériau.
Pour absorber le choc
du dérèglement du climat,
les villes doivent s'adapter.
MAJA VODANOVIC, responsable
de l'eau, Ville de Montréal
- La Ville doit être
plus comme une éponge,
on peut pas la minéraliser.
- Le ruissellement de l'eau
sur des surfaces imperméables
doit diminuer.
Boucherville vient de recevoir
une attestation d'excellence
pour avoir conçu un vaste
stationnement écoresponsable
JUDITH LAVOIE, Conseil régional
de l'environ. de la Montérégie
- Ils ont mis le paquet. Donc,
on a non seulement des pavés
drainants, on va aussi avoir des
pavés alvéolés, on a des noues
végétalisées. Il y a des
caissons qui vont filrer l'eau
jusqu'à la sortie, qui va après
dans un autre bassin
de rétention.
La première des priorités pour
l'adaptation des villes, selon
cette chercheuse, c'est :
SOPHIE VSOPHIE VSOPHIE VAN NEST.
en action climatique urbaine
- Verdir nos infrastructures.
Donc, c'est les routes, les
infrastructures d'eau pluviale,
donc c'est les verdir pour
s'adapter aux changements
climatiques, mais avoir
des coûts-bénéfices pour
les citoyens et citoyennes
en termes de qualité de vie.
- Comme cette initiative, qui
s'inspire d'une place inondable
à Rotterdam, au Pays-Bas.
Un parc résilient à Montréa
Aire de jeux, de pique-nique
et de promenade 95% du temps,
et en cas de forte pluie.
RÉMI HAF, conseiller en planif.
Service de l'eau, Ville de Mtl
- Les gens se rendent même pas
compte que c'est un bassin.
Donc, c'est des centaines de
mètres cubes, c'est l'équivalent
de 30 piscines hors terre
qui viennent s'accumuler
temporairement plutôt que
de continuer leur course
puis d'aller éventuellement
inonder les bâtiments.
- Les îlots de ch
un autre défi en ville.
Depuis 2011, obligation
dans l'arrondissement Rosemont,
que les toits neufés
soient blancs.
DAVID GRONDIN, arrondissement
Rosemont-La Petite-Patrie
- Une surface foncée, au soleil,
u'elle peut atteindre
une température à 50 degrés
plus haute que la température
de l'air, tandis qu'une surface
blanche va seulement atteindre1e
la température de l'air.
- Avec le même objectif, l'Union
européenne soutient le projet
Cour Oasis, qui prévoit
déminéraliser toutes les cours
d'école de Paris.
♪ ♪ ♪
L'idée chemine ici.
Cette école de Longueuil vient
de remplacer 1000 m2 d'asphalte,
mais il n'y a pas de programme
subventionné à grande échelle.
Autre idée qui pourrait être
importée : Séoul, qui avait
asséché et recouvert une rivière
d'une route, a décidé de revenir
aux sources, pour faire plus
de place à la nature en ville.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.